welcome everybody to this uh next event
in our external speakers series today we
have
uh professor sean carroll who's a
professor of physics at caltech and a
fractal faculty at the santa fe
institute soon to be joining johns
hopkins
um
jean orton also has uh has done a lot of
work on quantum mechanics as um
one of his main research fields so this
is also a great kickoff event for next
week's workshop on quantum causal models
and you might think about this when we
get into the q and a later on maybe we
can tap into that
on your website
on your website
it says you're interested in how the
world works at the deepest levels so i
think it's quite natural that you're
drawn into causality research and we're
very welcome to hear you talk about
the era of time and causal networks so
please join me in welcoming sean carroll
yeah i'm trying to think this might be
the first talk i've given at a
university
since the the end times began um so it's
good to be back and and speaking with
people in a real audience etc uh just to
manage expectations there will be no
quantum mechanics in this talk
whatsoever i do know some quantum
mechanics and i'm happy to answer
questions about it but this is very
classical and actually i know very
little about causality i know the people
in the audience who are engaged in a
program doing research in
causal networks and so forth this is not
my area i'm trying to learn about it so
i'm hoping to learn from you during the
talk i am in some sense an expert in the
arrow time and entropy and the physics
behind that so i'm going to try to
connect these two areas uh hopefully in
ways that will be
useful and this also this is you know
one of these questions the aerotime and
causal networks where it's not like
we're basing our major results on some
heroic technical calculation the actual
equations are pretty simple it's really
a matter of asking the question in
precisely the right way so what is the
question that we have in mind here's
what i take to be a standard question
that we ask in the world of causality uh
is it true that smoking causes cancer
or
is there some other confounding factor
like a genetic predis predisposition
that causes both smoking and cancer
for those of you who are not experts in
causality you might think we know the
answer to this and we do smoking causes
cancer but in the 60s it was not hard to
find people who you could pay to say
that maybe genetics caused both of them
and it was not the actual smoking that
was causing the cancer so how do you
know
you what you know is that there's a
correlation that people who smoke get
cancer but maybe if something else is
causing both of them stopping smoking
would not lower the incidence of cancer
that's the question that is addressed a
kind of question that is addressed by
causal analysis
here is a less common question that you
could address
uh does smoking cause cancer or does
cancer cause smoking very few people ask
this kind of question because there is a
subfield or a part of causal analysis
called causal discovery uh where we ask
about the directions of arrows in these
pictures so these are bayesian networks
or causal networks or whatever you want
to call them we have some random
variables and they are described by a
joint probability distribution and these
arrows it's a little bit
harder to exactly explain what the
arrows are but informally intuitively
they're supposed to tell you that at
least potentially
this variable can have a causal effect
on that variable okay and usually if
it's something like smoking in cancer
you presume from the start that you know
that cancer doesn't cause smoking it
comes after there's no mechanism you can
think of so you draw the arrow going
from smoking to cancer without thinking
about it too much and the hard work is
done asking if there are other arrows
but this question to those of a more
philosophical bent is kind of
interesting you know how do you know
exactly in what direction to draw the
arrows in particular a well-known fact
about causal influences in the world is
that the cause comes before the effect
you can argue about that one too but as
a general rule that's that's the way it
goes uh
uh directed in time and so the question
is why is that true and this is not as
far as i can tell maybe you can correct
me if i'm wrong but from trying to read
through these things is not a commonly
addressed question in fact it's the
opposite when you look at
methodologies of causal discovery one of
the rules you're told is if something
happens before something else
the arrow has to go from the thing
that's happening first to the thing that
is happening second so you're not
deriving that fact you're postulating
that fact when you're drawing your
arrows in the first place i want to know
how to derive that fact
why is it true that in the world what we
identify as a cause always comes before
what we identify as an effect
well this is clearly an aspect of what
we call the arrow of time right the fact
that the past and the future are
different in various ways if i show you
two pictures of somebody sufficiently
separated in time
i don't have to specify which of these
pictures is earlier and which of these
pictures is later you just know right
there are certain things that happen in
a very predictable way in a very clear
directionality to time we remember the
past and not the future right we have
records of the past we have photographs
fossils history books you can try to
predict the future but you do not have
an artifact here in the present day that
specifies some
particular thing that is happening in
the future that could have happened
otherwise like someone's birthday being
a certain date or someone uh having a
certain incident in their past etc
biological evolution personal aging of
organisms and the cause and effect arrow
these are all examples of the arrow of
time and if you were living
2 000 years ago 2500 years ago if you
were aristotle a friend of aristotle or
lived in that world this would not have
been a question you would not have
wondered about the arrow of time because
it was just obvious
the past and future are different things
it's like why should that why is there
be a surprise in the fact that there's
an asymmetry
between the past and the future the
present is what exists if you're a
presidentist if you're 2500 years ago
uh and the past is something that is
that happened in the past it's fixed the
future hasn't happened yet it's up for
grabs so it's obviously a totally
different kind of thing
then along comes physics and throws a
spanner in the works as it often does uh
ever since newtonian mechanics
our best guesses at the fundamental
equations of physics have had the
property they don't distinguish between
the past and the future they treat the
past and the future the same there's
again many different manifestations of
this or ways to talk about it here's
just one
the equation that governs in newtonian
mechanics the evolution of the orbit of
one object around another here it is uh
the second derivative with respect to
time of the position is given by
newton's inverse square law and what you
notice is that you don't need to
understand all these symbols they're not
that hard but if you send time to minus
time
if you reverse the direction of time
in this equation time only appears once
and it appears squared
so if you send t to minus t this
equation is unaltered okay so that is a
symmetry of the dynamics the fundamental
rules of newtonian mechanics work the
same
uh running forward or backward in time
another way of saying that is if you
made a movie of one object moving around
another one and you played that movie to
an another person but you played it
backwards
they would not notice anything funny
okay if you have a pendulum rocking back
and forth and you make a movie of that
play it backwards it looks the same
that's a manifestation of the
fundamental reversibility there is no
arrow of time deep down in the
fundamental laws of physics and this
remains true when you invent quantum
mechanics in the schrodinger equation
relativity or anything like that you got
a wrong factor of m there
equivalence principle
you're right i do
they're gonna revoke my physics license
they're gonna call me a philosopher now
but yes you're right there should not be
a little m there now that i think about
it okay sorry thanks
i told you patrick we should not record
this i told him we shouldn't record it
all right this is evidence i made up
these slides uh on the car ride home
okay
uh
here is why we do have
an arrow of time in the world the air of
time is not fundamental but it is there
in the emergent larger scale world the
macroscopic world in which we find
ourselves because of this rule the
second law of thermodynamics
second law of thermodynamics the first
law just says energy is conserved no big
deal the second law says that entropy
increases we'll get to what entropy is
at a technical level in a minute but
roughly speaking it's a measure of the
disorderliness of something the
randomness the disorganization this is
not the ideal picture but it's a pretty
picture of the evolution from an
unbroken egg to a broken egg to
scrambled eggs uh disorder is increasing
entropy is increasing and this happens
again if i made a movie of breaking the
egg and turning into scrambled eggs
you would know if i played that movie
backwards right you don't see movies
where you take scrambled eggs and turn
them into an unbroken egg that doesn't
happen there's a profound pronounced
directionality to this macroscopic
phenomenon because entropy is increasing
so what i want to claim is
i haven't explained this phenomenon in
detail yet but i'm going to claim that
the only reason there is an asymmetry
between the past and future in the world
is because entropy is increasing over
time and therefore if there's any other
phenomenon that you know about that
indicates a asymmetry an asymmetry
between past and future is ultimately
because entropy is increasing
and that includes the fact that
causality has an arrow of time so we
should be able to trace the fact that
causes precede effects to the fact that
entropy is increasing over time and so
that's the claim
the reason why uh there's causes
perceived effects is because entropy is
increasing with time
the the thing to be to note here
is that you know both the starting point
and the ending point
the starting point is entropy is
increasing the ending point is that
causes precede effects it is famously
hard to figure out
how to connect correctly the beginning
point to the ending point if you know
both of them it's not like we don't know
the answer yet we're looking to find it
we know what the answer is causes
precede effects so there are many wrong
ways to get the right answer there are
many ways to trick yourself into
thinking that you have established the
connection between these two things
that's what we're trying to figure out
so i i think maybe we can make some
progress there uh but maybe you disagree
we'll find out
here's the example i want you to keep in
mind uh not from any personal experience
but sometimes people knock over glasses
of wine and they fall on the floor okay
this you may have seen this happen in
the world so to formalize this we're
going to set up a set of random
variables
x y and z
and the random variable x is that at
seven o'clock
am or pm i presume it's pm but i don't
judge i don't know what wine o'clock is
uh in berkeley
uh i either
swing my arm or i don't that's a one bit
worth of information random variable uh
at seven o'clock plus one second the
glass falls off the table or it doesn't
and at seven o'clock at two seconds
there is wine now on the floor or there
isn't
okay
these are the three random variables and
they're correlated with each other in
the real world in fact to make things
simple we're going to assume the
correlations are perfect so in other
words if there is no y on the floor at
702 then i did not swing my arm and the
glass did not fall if there is wine on
the floor then i did swing my arm the
glass did fall with probability one okay
so it's not like likely it's it's a
hundred it's not just likely it's a
hundred percent
what you notice about that is that we'll
come back to this but this joint
probability distribution for the three
random variables is entirely symmetric
with respect to time
right if i tell you at eight o'clock
that there was wine on the floor at
seven o'clock plus two seconds you know
with certainty the two seconds earlier i
swung my arm okay within i'm assuming
this is true i'm not
deriving it but let's imagine that is
the situation that we're considering so
there's no arrow of time in the
probability distribution as yet right
if we wanted to do causal analysis
on this situation we would
draw a little causal network i don't
know why i'm not
oh yeah i know why
come on there we go
here's a causal network very very simple
one again we're not going to need a lot
of advanced level concepts as far as
causality is concerned
swinging my arm glass is falling whine
on the floor and we're going to ask the
question does knocking over glass the
glass cause the wine to spill onto the
floor
yes the answer is yes don't i'm not
holding you in suspense okay that's the
correct answer but we're going to think
about it really carefully and you know
what i'm going to talk about there is
this idea of the do operator
introduced by judea pearl
and the idea is that you can ask whether
or not this particular
fact
that the glass is being knocked over or
not
is what is causally responsible for
there being wine on the floor and you
ask it by intervening
and doing this do operator acting on the
y variable so basically you break the
connection between what is called the
parent the if you have these arrows
pointing from one node to another this
is the parent of x is the parent of y
because an arrow points from x to one so
you break that connection so you say
forget about the fact that in the real
world
if i swing my arm the wine glass falls
if i don't i don't just say whatever my
arm was doing who cares doesn't matter
but i'm going to let the wine glass
either fall or not
and subsequent to that i will let the
ordinary laws of physics do whatever
they do so this do operator
says that there's no
correlation anymore
between x and y but y could either be
yes the wine glass falls or no it
doesn't
and we let it do its influence on z and
what pearl says is that
you can say that y is exerting a causal
influence on z if
in this do operator if you do one
variable one value so you say that i did
the glass did fall over
if i find there is a correlation so the
glass falling over changes the
probability distribution of the wine
being on the floor then there is a
causal influence okay so the thing
you're trying to get rid of are these
correlations caused by something else if
you notice that every time you go
outside if it's sunny outside uh so
there's no rain and no one has an
umbrella up
if it's raining it's raining and
everyone has their umbrella up or is the
umbrella causing the rain so the dew
operator says no i can go in there and
just force someone to put their umbrella
up and i see it does not start raining
so this is how to disentangle these
correlations
uh the thing about the do operator is
that you can't actually calculate its
action just from the original
probability distribution because the
original probability distribution has a
lock step relationship
between me swinging my arm and the wind
glass point yes
i can't hear you with mass sorry there
should be a y in that on the in the
numerator
that's very possibly true it could be a
typo i'm sorry i need to look it up i
don't have that in my brain yeah thank
you
so
for those of you who don't know i have a
podcast called mindscape and i've
recently interviewed judea pearl for the
podcast it has not yet been
published so i'm letting you in uh on
this information and pearl says this is
why statisticians get irritated by the
do operator because you can't figure out
its action just from knowing the data
the data that are implied by this actual
probability distribution you have to
either do some extra experiments that
are outside your original data set or
use your brain somehow right do thought
experiments or something like that and
the reason why that is from the
philosophical point of view is that
causality by its nature is a
counterfactual notion it is saying
something like if x had not happened
then y would have not happened or
something like that but x did happen so
what do you mean by this counter factual
statement the do operator is a way to
sort of put quantitative meat on those
counterfactual bones by saying this is
what we mean by uh making these
statements about worlds that did not
happen
what you have to buy into to let that
happen is to break the connection
between x and y so to break the
laws of physics if you want in the real
world if i swing my arm the wine glass
is going to fall i'm assuming i'm
swinging it in exactly that place and if
i don't swing it it won't in this world
in this discussion we have to imagine
worlds where i swing my arm but it just
bounces harmlessly off the wine glass
or i don't swing my arm and the wine
glass just hops off the table okay
that's what we're assuming
counterfactually is allowed in this
discussion it's perfectly okay to do
that because after that you let the laws
of physics do what they do and that's
what you're asking questions about
okay so you all knew that most of you
knew that there might be some
interlopers here but the causality
people knew all that
here is the point
again the probability distribution that
is in the actual data has no
arrow of time if you know
whether i swung my arm or not you know
whether the wind's on the floor and vice
versa just as well
therefore you might be tempted to ask is
it possible that the fact that causes
always precede effects in time
is just a convention
is it just a convenient way for us to
think given other things about the world
or
could we have just as well
draw on a causal network with the arrows
going the other way
i mean the probability distribution is
the same so can you just draw it going
this way just as well
and the answer is no you can't do that
there are good reasons to draw the
arrows going this way and the reasons
are because the reasons are not due to
the initial probability distribution the
reasons have to do with those
counterfactual statements
that come into defining the do operator
okay in these other possible worlds that
we're comparing our actual world to
uh there is an arrow of time that is
going to matter
and that's what i want to sort of
explain
how do we explain that well we have this
thing called entropy which is going to
explain the arrow of time so other
people in the room are too familiar with
this but maybe some of you haven't seen
it this is ludwig boltzmann this is his
gravestone in vienna he has an equation
on his gravestone i always tell my
graduate students
what is the equation that will be on
your gravestone someday uh boltzmann
never wrote this equation down that's
even better this was written down by
planck he was trying to translate things
boltzmann had said
but it's a worthy equation have on your
gravestone because it is the
relationship between entropy which was
invented as a concept in the early 19th
century
and microscopic physics in this case in
the theory of atoms and molecules okay
when entropy was invented physicists
didn't believe in atoms
they couldn't see them even when
boltzmann was at a peak of his success
he had colleagues like ernst mock who
didn't believe in atoms because as a
philosophical stance they said that
atoms were an unfalsifiable unobservable
hypothesis and should not be allowed in
discussions of science
happily we don't have discussions like
that anymore in cosmology but uh back in
the day you know your philosophical
stances could influence what you what
you thought boltzmann was convinced that
there was adams and he knew about the
second law of thermodynamics so he
wanted to say
not just as a fact that entropy
increased he wanted to derive it
he wanted to explain why entropy
increased and he could do that by
defining what entropy is in terms of the
microscopic theory of atoms and
particles so what he said was look if
you look at something like an egg like a
cup of coffee with cream mixing in it
like
air molecules dispersing through a box
of gas
there are things you see
literally you're looking at it you
observe certain features of the stuff
you don't see the individual particles
right you don't see the individual atoms
in every single one of them with your
eyes you see some macroscopic features
so we can coarse grain the system we can
define equivalence classes
macro states which are these regions
this is all the states you can have the
entire space of states and you can call
two states equivalent if they look the
same to you macroscopically okay so in
the cup of coffee there are many ways to
rearrange the specific atoms and
molecules that look the same to us
microscopically and what boltzmann did
is he defined the entropy to be
proportional to the logarithm of the
number of microstates specific exact
full descriptions of the system within
the macro state
so
why does entropy go up with time
there are two facts you need to know to
understand why entropy goes up with time
one is explained by boltzmann namely
that there are way more ways to be high
entropy than to be low entropy that is
in the definition of entropy uh
generally even though it's just a
logarithm generally the volume of
macrostates corresponding to high
entropy states is enormously larger than
those in low entropy states so there are
many many more high entropy microstates
that's one thing you need to know the
other thing is you need to start with a
low entropy state
that's trickier we don't understand that
one nearly as well but if you start in a
low entropy state
and let it evolve with overwhelming
probability the entropy will increase
over time just because there are more
ways to be high entropy than to be low
entropy if you start with a deck of
cards in order and you shuffle them they
will shuffle into some random
configuration if you start in random
configuration and shuffle them they will
not order themselves there are far fewer
ways to be ordered than to be disordered
now
this question of why we start in the low
entropy state is the tricky one so let's
imagine that so what boltzmann says in
other words is
starting from the universe today
he can predict why tomorrow the entropy
will be higher
because there's a lot more ways to be
high entropy what he can't explain is
why the entropy was lower yesterday
he wrote about it he tried uh and he
claimed it was all perfectly sensible
and then he
gave four different possible
explanations which were mutually
inconsistent so we didn't quite get the
right answer back in the day but the
answer is why was the entropy lower
yesterday than it is today the answer is
because it was even lower the day before
yesterday
why is that true because the entry was
even lower the day before that and it
goes all the way back to the big bang 14
billion years ago so if all you knew
was that the entropy today this is
supposed to be today at t equals 500 in
this little numerical simulation if all
you knew is the entropy was much lower
than one where one is the maximum
entropy of your system
then because the underlying laws are
time reversal and variant
you would predict on average the same
evolution toward the past in the future
so if all you knew was the current macro
state and the dynamical laws of physics
you would predict that both the future
and the past had higher entropy than
today that is not correct so you would
have gotten it wrong how do you get it
right you say you invoke what is called
the past hypothesis which is simply the
statement that our universe began in a
very low entropy state okay
boltzmann didn't talk about that because
he didn't know about the big bang etc he
could have there's a uh another possible
history of physics where boltzmann said
you know what entropy's been going up
for a long time
it must have started somewhere the
universe universe must have started a
finite number of years ago
he could have invented the big bang
before general general relativity was
invented but he didn't
no one asked how the sun and other stars
could have been shining for an infinite
number of years in a finite universe but
they could have
yes so um in this like physics model in
like in the slide uh before this one
oh yes
thank you again in the slide before this
this one should i be so uh we're not
getting to the fourth the fourth the
formalities but should i be thinking
about
states like randomly ups
hating and that what i'm seeing here is
like
one run of that up
hate or maybe like like the average be a
behavior of the end entropy um if you
make sure i'm on the same page that
there is something
random
in the way that things are up
so in the real world there's not
anything random like i said all of the
discussion here is gonna be perfectly
classical this mathematical mathematica
calculation was in fact random so i put
some random numbers in there what that
represents in the real world is just
uncertainties about the microscopic data
okay so in the real world the apparent
randomness comes from the fact that we
don't know the exact microstate but
there's no real randomness
okay thank you
so if it's much
harder
my question is about the explanation you
gave for this slide if it's much harder
to move from
a
low entropy state
sorry from a high entropy state to a low
entropy state then vice versa
why would you be in an agnostic position
if you just see a
low entropy state
i didn't you slowed down too much there
at the end yeah sorry i think i said
something backwards so you you said you
observed that today we're at a
relatively low entropy state right the
arrow of the non-existence of an arrow
of time and the laws of physics suggests
that you should be agnostic about that
you should think that the future and
past were both higher entropy because
that's more likely but you had also said
previously explaining boltzmann's
thinking that it is more difficult to
move from a
a high entropy state to a low entropy
state than to move from a low entropy
state to a high entropy state so
wouldn't that already suggest that the
past was not symmetric to the future
no because that statement is also true
going from the future to the past
so whatever you can analyze i see yeah
yes thank you i'm glad you answered your
own question so but let me let me
mention in passing uh boltzmann was the
first person to invent the multiverse
and the anthropic principle for exactly
this reason he knew that if you just
picked a random point in the evolution
of the universe you should be at maximum
entropy
but you're not because life cannot exist
in a universe of maximum entropy so he
said maybe we live in a temporary
decrease boltzmann said maybe we do live
in in this point
that's not correct it doesn't work but
that was he guessed that what actually
works is that long before now 14 billion
years before now we were in a very very
low entropy state okay
so i call this the past hypothesis that
we start in low entropy state and you
might think
uh if you know a little bit but not
enough cosmology you might think well
wait the early universe was a thermal
bath of particles isn't that high
entropy no it is very low entropy
because it is gravitationally
undisturbed it's very very smooth very
very homogeneous that turns out if you
run the numbers to be very very low
entropy the other question you might ask
is why is it a hypothesis rather than an
observation don't we make pictures of
the early universe and see that it's low
entropy
also no
well we make pictures of is the
radiation field of the cosmic microwave
background at our telescopes today
right we have wmap and planck up there
in the sky
detecting photons we extrapolate them
backward to make statements about what
the early universe was like under the
assumption that the entropy was lower at
early times if we didn't have that
assumption it is overwhelmingly likely
that the photons just randomly
fluctuated into our telescope and have
no relationship to the lumpiness of the
early universe so you need this past
hypothesis to make sense of cosmology so
there's a whole other talk
cosmology based trying to explain why
the early universe had low entropy this
is not a solved question in cosmology
right now
but the claim is that this fact you
started with low entropy i knew it all
right
sorry
we only needed to make sense of
cosmology rather than any experiment
no the other way around we need
cosmology to make sense of it
so it is the job of cosmologists to
explain why the early universe had low
entropy once you do that like you say
you need to make that assumption to do
all of
science arriving at wmf uh about any
phone that's arriving okay more
experiment over there
absolutely
the wmap comment was only to
make people
understand that we do not
have
empirical information of the smoothness
of the early universe
absent a hypothesis of early low entropy
okay so what does that get you how does
this increase of entropy explain the
arrow of time so this is the one slide
this is the conceptually important slide
for the whole talk
it's trivial to understand that's the
good news but you better understand it
uh to understand what comes next so
one of the features of the arrow time is
that we have memories of the past and
not the future and i don't mean
necessarily memories in your brain i
mean any records photographs like we
said okay fossils artifacts here is a
memory this is a broken egg you're
walking down the sidewalk you come
across a broken egg lying on the cycle
for some reason you're in a
philosophical mood and you ask yourself
what is the future of that egg likely to
involve
the answer is you don't know there's
many possible futures for the egg it
could just sit there for a long time a
rainstorm could wash it away dogs could
come by and eat it or whatever right
there's many possible features but if
you ask yourself what did the past of
that egg most likely involve
would say i bet that there used to be an
unbroken egg and somebody dropped it
right it's pretty you don't know exactly
when etc but the space of possibilities
is smaller
why is that
why can you say more about the past
based on that current data that you have
the answer is not just in the laws of
physics if you have some macroscopic
information which you do about the
present day
and you think that that macroscopic
information is compatible with a whole
bunch of microstates and you have
deterministic evolution of those
microstates both from the past and
toward the future then the number of
possible futures is precisely equal to
the number of possible paths
there's no inequality there
the reason why
you can draw conclusions about the past
from this that you can't draw from the
future is that you also think that we
started with a low entropy past
and what you are secretly asking
yourself is not just from this egg what
can i say about the past but
conditionalizing on both that egg and
the low entropy past
what can i say about the in between
past the trajectory so it is not true
that in the space of all possible
configurations of the universe
given a broken egg there used to be an
unbroken egg with high probability
given just the broken egg most of them
randomly fluctuated into existence from
all the possible molecules in the
universe it's similar and not right away
not like rapidly it's just like running
the movie you expect for the future but
running it backwards okay
instead we think that we came from a low
entropy past and we say that
conditionalizing on that low entropy
past how is it most likely to get an egg
on the floor or the sidewalk and the
answer is via an unbroken net
the details
take some working out there but that's
the fundamental thing so you get the
point you need to get your brain is
you can't without that low entropy past
counted this as a memory telling you
something about a record telling you
something about an event that you would
conventionally attach with it in the
past yes
so um
so so yes so even if i don't know any
physics which i know very little
i i'm still biased to think that the
past was an unbroken
egg that fell on the ground why is it
why is it that human brains are biased
have this bias
that the past is low entropy and the
i mean you're answering your own
question every moment of your life
you've been embedded in an arrow of time
that is very very strong every sequence
of events you've ever seen in time has
been one of increasing entropy you you
deepen your bones think that entropy
just should increase
it is very hard to put yourself in the
mindset of someone who doesn't have a
past hypothesis to rely on
so it's a it's a bias of the human brain
oh absolutely but
that made it into physics
yeah so the whole question of why
there's narrow time in the first place
remember aristotle never asked it's just
obvious right this is a question that
came was forced on to us by the
introduction of reversible deterministic
rules in the invention of classical
mechanics but we also have these
statistical facts about initial
conditions that bias our feeling for how
those deterministic rules show up in the
microscopic world
with zero time
but the physics say that the physics is
reversible rather than
the microphysics is reversible look
aristotle says if i have a cup on the
table
and i push it and i stop pushing it it
stops
he's right it just stopped right but the
laws of physics say that the natural
state of things is to move a constant
velocity
the reconciliation is there's something
called friction
and the that active friction that little
sound you hear
increases the entropy of the universe
in the space of all possibilities
without a low entropy initial past it is
equally likely that sound waves will
focus in on the cup and push it backward
in the real world that never happens
i was just wondering if i should be
thinking about the probability
distribution of the past states like
when you say the ones the infrared
trajectories are the one that i
think has the highest probability mass
and that's kind of what i'm
good so there is a whole debate in the
foundations of statistical mechanics
literature as to how to precisely
formulate the past hypothesis
somehow you want to
have the highest possible entropy that
is compatible with what we actually see
so the past hypothesis is not just the
early universe has low entropy
it it's that the universe starts in a
state of low entropy with the feature
that is not surprising that it evolved
into the later universe we see today and
turning those words into a precise
statement is an ongoing
thing so what i'm saying is i don't know
read the literature
okay thank you okay
good
so we want to do this but we're going to
do this for causality now okay uh and so
despite my best intentions this is
taking longer than i thought so i'm
gonna have to speed up a little bit uh
the setup is to first we're gonna core
screen allah boltzmann we're gonna
divide our description of a system into
macro states and micro variables within
those macro states we're going to define
a probability distribution that evolves
over time starting with the low entropy
past there'll be a crucial input from
physics which is that micro variables
i'll explain this more but micro
variables are faster
than macro variables so they will
actually equilibrate faster there's
multi-scale to the dynamics and as a
result of all this the markovian
property of evolving from one moment to
another in the macro world evolves going
forward works going forward in time but
does not work going backwards and that
is what is going to prevent us from
drawing our arrows backward in the
causal diagrams
i'm going to make sense of all this uh
now so just to convince you that there's
work to be done we're gonna have some
symbols some greek letters
uh we're imagining a system which is
supposed to be the whole universe or
anything you know pretty big i'm a
cosmologist by training i talk about the
universe you can talk about the earth or
something smaller the lab
there is we're doing classical mechanics
there is a phase space capital omega and
there is a microstate there is one
actual state of the world
okay we don't know what it is though we
have some incomplete information about
that and if you believe in deterministic
underlying laws that state evolves in
time in a reversible way so it's
completely deterministic if you know q1
then you know q2 and q3 but also vice
versa so i
cheekily indicated that by putting
arrows both sides of the time axis here
then we're going to coarse grain so we
first divide the whole universe into
subsystems
you me the lab the air all these
different subsystems and each one of
them has a microstate so the whole
system can be defined by all these
microstates of all the subsystems and
again
at this level the evolution is still
perfectly deterministic forward and
backward we have not coarse grained yet
i think i slipped when i said that
now we coarse grain so this is now let's
slow down a little bit because this is
the important part
um
in this
in each subsystem this this notation is
supposed to mean this is a subsystem
this is like a person or a place or a
thing
i don't know a box of gas a star
whatever some part of the universe okay
and we're going to describe that part of
the universe in a coarse grained way by
dividing its coordinates into
macroscopically observable facts
and other facts which we'll call the
micro variables okay so
x is the set of macroscopic variables
that we need to that's what we actually
see when we look at the system and then
all the additional things we don't see
are encoded in these micro variables
wide
okay so the a very trivial example is
the earth moving around the sun under
the force of gravity
the earth has roughly 10 to the 50th
atoms in it but to predict its motion
around the sun i do not need to tell you
the position of velocity of 10 to the
50th atoms all i need to tell you is the
center of mass position and velocity six
numbers because there's three dimensions
of space
okay so the xa's for the earth moving
around the sun or any other celestial
mechanics problem is just center of mass
coordinates and velocity
and all the ya's are all the relative
positions of all the atoms and other
things within the earth okay
that's one possible course graining
there's a whole other philosophy
discussion about why are there certain
good course grainings and certain bad
ones but that's another yet another day
uh a more common example from the
stateneck point of view is you know you
drop some i don't know why this looks
like a sugar cube a purple sugar cube
into some liquid but anyway you drop one
substance into another one and it
diffuses okay
so in this description what we mean by
the macro variables xa
is the distribution through the vessel
of the purple stuff
it starts all concentrated it spreads
out a little bit it eventually fills the
glass
the y's are the individual positions
within that macroscopic set of
constraints okay
so we do that this is a standard
stat mech move that started with
boltzmann and maxwell and their friends
and uh just so as not to be too serious
here there's a fun name that has been
given to this called the mentaculous
this is borrowed from uh the coen
brothers movie a serious man with the
star of the movie the protagonist is a
physicist
who is slightly crazy he has a brother
who is completely crazy and the brother
carries around a book that he calls the
mentalist which he says is a probability
map of the world it's a probability of
every single thing that happens in the
world here it is it looks almost like a
causal network
um so what we have in our setup is a
probability distribution at any one time
over the set of all the microstates
which we can divide up into a
probability distribution over the macro
variables and the micro variables
if we want to we can just integrate out
the micro variables to get a macro
probability distribution
and then you can that's at one time and
you can just use the fundamental laws of
physics to evolve it forward or backward
equally well so the only thing i'm
saying here is that what you know is
that given a state a microstate and
deterministic underlying laws you can
evolve it forward or backward in time
i'm just saying here you can do the same
for the whole probability distribution
because you just sort of within the
probability distribution evolve all the
microstates and get another probability
distribution at other moments in time
so david albert and barry lower have
called this
set of probabilities at all times the
mintaculous
and they actually got permission from
the cohen brothers to do this and then
so they write papers about deriving
emerging phenomena from the mentalist
uh
here is the physics input to my
discussion which i already warned you
about which is that micro variables
evolve rapidly
what does that mean in particular they
equilibrate
rapidly so here is a picture of a system
with a medium-sized entropy mixing cream
into coffee right so it's not all mixed
yet but it's on the way
so there's some macro distribution so
macro description a macro state the xa x
alpha variables
and you can you know you've seen this
before right in your real world you know
how the cream mixes into the coffee the
point i'm making is that at any one
moment of time
if you fix the macro state so you're
looking at some particular distribution
of where the cream is and where the
coffee is there's all these micro
variables but the molecules are bumping
into each other really really rapidly
so given the constraints of being in
that macroscopic configuration
other than that
the micro variables are in their highest
entropy state or evolve to their highest
entropy state on a very very short time
scale so to a very very good
approximation at every time
the macro variables are evolving slowly
and we track what they're doing but
within that macro state the micro
variables are in a known distribution
the equilibrium distribution it might
depend on the temperature of the bath
they're in and all that stuff the other
variables but it's a calculable known
thing
so even though you can only observe the
macro variables to a very good
approximation you know what the micro
variables
are at least you know what their
probability distribution is there are
some mathematical caveats we won't get
into but that's a good way of thinking
about it
so what that means is this looks like
the same picture i drew before but now
this is just for macro variables okay so
the micro variables we think we know
what their probability distribution is
so we're not going to track them anymore
the point of this plot is if i take if i
tell you
the probability distribution of all the
different macroscopic configurations the
world can be in
that's this moment of time i don't know
if you can see the
laser pointer it's this moment of time
number two that's the time variable okay
and then i could use the underlying laws
of physics to evolve it either backward
or forward in time
laws of physics are completely um
time reversal invariant i could build up
a master distribution of all of the
different things at all moments of time
but i don't do that
because i know there was a low entropy
passed what i actually do is start with
the low entropy past
and i only evolve it toward the future
and then if you want you can update like
a good bayesian by conditionalizing on
observations what is happening in this
big probability distribution is of
course there's a lot of times when the
probabilities
describe mutually inconsistent things
right the volcano erupted or it didn't
and this whole probability distribution
includes both volcano erupted and it
didn't you could update if you wanted to
on the fact that i saw the volcano erupt
but you don't have to
uh this is kind of like quantum
mechanics but it's not quantum mechanics
there's nothing interfering there's no
complex numbers it's just a classical
probability distribution okay
so the important physics fact about this
is that the evolution is markovian that
is to say since i'm starting at the past
in the low entropy state
and i know
the micro variable probability
distribution there is a known unique
deterministic evolution of this
probability distribution forward in time
that's what markovian means i can go
from one moment in time to the next one
i don't need to keep into account
um
knowledge of the past as well so to
update from moment two to moment three i
don't need to know what moment one was
doing i just need to know moment two is
do
what that means so and that's because
the micro variables are sort of just
quickly equilibrate they're not secretly
conspiring to do something weird in the
future so there's nothing being set up
in the past to surprise you in the
future that's the assumption that we're
working on and it's very physically
plausible and you couldn't do
statistical mechanics without it
so it's okay and so this suggests
arrows right and it's perfectly okay
these are correct arrows to draw going
from the conditions of
macroscopic systems at one moment of
time to the future
this is why it is natural i haven't
shown this the only thing to do
but it is sensible and natural to draw
the arrows to go from the past and the
future because that is the direction in
which things are markov
right they're not the other way around
that's that was the point of the ag
example if all you know
is the macro distribution at moment two
you cannot just use the laws of physics
to derive the correct macro distribution
of moment one you also need to
conditionalize
on the low entropy past
all right so i've been using the word
entropy a lot here's the actual
definition of entropy in this land of
probability distributions rather than
coarse grainings uh given a probability
distribution over some variables the
entropy is minus the integral of the
probability times the log of the
probability
which if you recognize it if you work
with these kinds of things this is just
the expectation of one over the log of
the probability in that probability
distribution
so
this is sort of a
side light but just so you're clear on
what is going on here you could do this
separately
for the macro variables and the micro
variables you could define the entropy
of the macro variables what does that
mean well you have the volcano
it could erupt or not erupt so there's a
probability distribution over did it
erupt and i could calculate the entropy
of that probability distribution you
might say aha that entropy should go up
with time because there's the second law
and in the past it didn't erupt but in
the future there's uncertainty so the
entropy goes up
that is not right
the macroscopic entropy that you can
define here
could go up or down
there's no law of physics that says that
in fact look at what happens here
the purple stuff
converges on a single unique
distribution
right we know what the distribution is
the macro variables
the micro variables within that
distribution that's where the second law
kicks in so knowing what the macroscopic
configuration is
as the microscopic configuration changes
the entropy of the associated
microscopic variables goes up with time
that's what we that's you know the
purple stuff is expanding through the
glass
okay so that's just if your friends ask
you what is the second law it has to do
with these microscopic variables
and their entropy increasing
which is a reminder
that
there's another thing that you might
have said and gone wrong and i only say
this because i thought it and it was
wrong so you have to teach yourself
these things
um
toward the future with the volcano
example in mind or a flipping coin
example in mind right there are many
examples we have
of having a system now in some macro
state but not being able to predict what
will happen next who will win the
presidential election who will win the
nba championship etc right so if you
have a probability distribution over all
those things you might imagine that its
entropy goes up
as its uncertainty increases with time
you flip a coin you're in a single macro
state its macro entropy is zero
you flip a coin it gets one bits worth
of macroentropy in the future
but that's not why you draw the arrows
in the causal diagram going from the
past to the future because of these
diverging dynamics number one there's
plenty of deterministic dynamics even in
the macroscopic world you can predict
eclipses in the future and when the sun
is going to rise etc
in situations where the entropy increase
is not noticeable
but also there are many examples where
two different states macro states
converge to the same macro state
so the macro entropy goes down
so in the world of the macro variables
there for any given subsystem the
entropy could go up or down or anything
that is not the arrow of time that is
not the reason why we draw our arrows in
the causal diagram in that direction
it is this is just i can't help but
noticing about talking about this even
though it's not what the talk is about
you'll grant me two slides on this
it is related
to the origin of complexity in the
universe
okay so if you look at here's a closed
system that's entropy is increasing
cream on the top coffee on the bottom
these are actually all the same time but
you can get what i'm trying to represent
here entropy is increasing from left to
right right nope this is very low
entropy all separated it's a very high
entropy all mixed together
but think about simplicity versus
complexity where i literally mean the
amount of information you'd have to give
me to describe this image you could
literally take a
photograph of it and compress it on a
jpeg font okay
the leftmost image is very simple
all the creams on the top all the
coffees in the bottom that's the full
description with the macro state
the right hand image is also very simple
they're all mixed together
even though this is low entropy and high
entropy this is simple and this is
simple and it's in between that things
are complex there's a specific
non-trivial mixing pattern
little fractal swirls etc
and this turns out to be a very common
behavior it's not universal or necessary
but it's very allowed
so you can go from low entropy to high
entropy and it's in between
that you have the ability to be complex
this is not just uh cups of coffee the
universe does the same thing the very
early universe was very very low entropy
and very simple this is a photograph of
the very early universe
one second after the big bang
it's not really a photograph it's a
white rectangle that i tilted in
powerpoint okay there's no photographs
of the universe one second after big
bang but we know what it looked like it
was very hot and very very very smooth
several hundred thousand years later in
homogeneities had begun to grow under
the force of gravity this is a
photograph of the cosmic microwave
background a few hundred thousand years
later a few tens of billions of years
later this is the current universe with
stars and galaxies and it's very complex
but that complexity is going away the
universe is accelerating the stars are
burning out they will fall into black
holes those black holes will evaporate
the last black hole evaporates about a
google years from now
and that is the highest entropy state of
the universe and it is also very simple
so when people say you know
life
is a fight against the increase of
entropy
they have it exactly wrong
the only reason life is possible is
because entropy is increasing if entropy
weren't increasing we'd be in thermal
equilibrium there'd be no life around so
life is parasitic upon the fact that
entropy increases that's why complex
structures can arrive rise in the
universe just wanted to let you know
okay back to the glass of wine we can
answer this question now very very
easily we've done all the work all the
setup
is all trivial now
so the question is given this
probability distribution between
my arm swinging the glass falling and
the wine being on the floor which is
perfectly reversible in time are we
allowed this is what we usually do we
say if you put the do operator in the
middle you can show that
the glass falling causes the wine to be
on the floor and we're asking is it okay
to reverse that could we just as well
have said that it is the wine the glass
falling that caused my arm to move or to
make it grammatically correct
uh
is the fact that the glass will fall the
reason why i am swinging my arm
the answer is no but we're trying to
figure out why the answer is no the
reason why is because the backwards in
time evolution is not
markovian
you can't draw a causal network that the
original causal network that you
interfered with to put that do operator
on there the actual past distribution
in the real world the mentalis
is not derivable just from the current
state and the laws of physics you need
to also conditionalize on something in
the future of that
and what that means is
in the causal network language uh sorry
i'm just repeating myself here if all we
knew
and this is the hard thing to sort of
appreciate intuitively because of
exactly your question we're embedded in
the arrow of time and it's hard for us
to reason counterfactually
if you didn't know
that there was a low entropy passed but
you did know that the wine glass was
falling over
you would not be able to say oh i
probably swung my arm or someone
probably knocked it over
in the space of all possible ways the
wine glass could fall most of them are
the wine glass just randomly jiggling
its molecules and falling over
now that never happens in the real world
because we're coming from a low entropy
past but in the space of all possible
things that could happen that is
overwhelmingly what you would predict
okay so just from the current macro
state including the fact that wineglass
is falling over you would not retrodict
me swinging my arm you also need the
early universe um evidence and
that's not in the causal network that's
the point
here is the good causal network with the
arrows pointing from the past to the
future if you try to say can i just
reverse the arrows
the answer is no
there is a technical definition of when
it is okay to draw these arrows in in
the sense that when is it okay to
consider a certain set of variables as
the parent of another variable and the
answer is you have to be able to
reconstruct the whole graph
just from knowing the dependence of
every variable on its parents
so you don't need to separately know its
dependence on other things the parents
of the variables are all you need to
know to reconstruct the whole
probability distribution
if i reversed the arrows that wouldn't
be the kicks
but i could make a graph with reversed
arrows
but they would have some arrows that
loop around
you would need to have the low entropy
passed as the parents of everything
so you could not just draw arrows going
from the future to the past using the
laws of physics that would not be that
would
give you a mistake because you would
predict that entry would go up as you go
from the present to the past that's
wrong
so
the answer is if you want maybe you
don't but if you want to draw a causal
network
where the arrows just go from one moment
in time to the next or the previous
the fact that the entropy of the early
universe was low implies you will only
get the right answer if those arrows are
pointing from the past to the future not
the other way around
that's the punchline
so
therefore
i claim the low entropy past is the
explanation of the arrow of time and
again
you've been lots of us have been
convinced this is correct for a very
very long time the people who generally
think about this kind of question are
not also generally up on
the most recent thinking about causal
networks and things like that so i think
it's a it's a natural kind of synergy to
put these two things together and use
the causal network analysis uh to
pinpoint why exactly
increasing entropy is relevant to the
question of um why causes precedent
effects now when i first started working
on the question of the arrow time you
know why is the past difference in the
future uh someone asked a slightly wise
cracky way so what's your next project
going to be on the mystery of
alphabetical order
the joke being that you know look we all
know the past came first and then the
future like this is not a thing that we
have to worry about right you know
causes perceived effects i was born
young i will grow older like that's not
something that requires explanation
um i mean it's a known fact that is true
i'm not denying that the arrow time is
real but i do think it is actually very
very valuable to understand why
in a way that we mostly do but not
completely and this kind of work is a
step in that direction it's part of the
much bigger project right we have and
again it goes back to the question of
why we're so convinced that the arrow
time is just there that if you see a
broken egg there must have been an
unbroken egg right we're convinced of
that why
because there is what philosophers call
the manifest image of the world the
picture of the world that we have just
from growing up and moving around in it
biology and evolution have something to
do with it but also training and
experience and learning has something to
do with it also we put together a folk
image of the world consisting of tables
and chairs and processes like cause
effect relationships and in that world
if you don't keep pushing the cup it's
going to stop moving momentum is not
conserved in that world and that world
is very natural and intuitive to us
but science gives us a different image
of the world it says that there's this
cup and this table are made of atoms and
the atoms obey reversible laws and
actually there are things called
relativity and quantum mechanics and the
project of connecting those is both
intrinsically intellectually interesting
but also will potentially teach us
things so i think there are many many
many questions remaining unanswered in
this broader project again most of these
you have guesses that are probably
pretty good and it's not a matter of
completely starting from scratch so much
as it is a matter of sharpening up your
guesses into formal derivations and
careful statements
i divided the world into subsystems
halfway through the talk who ordered
that where did that come from who says
how to divide the macro state of the
whole state of the world into a state of
subsystems why do i not need to know
the microscopic theory in order to have
a macroscopic understanding of the world
why was aristotle able to say something
about cups of coffee and so forth
without knowing about newton's laws of
motion right why are there emergent and
autonomous higher level laws that are
independent or at least not requiring
knowledge of the lower level laws do the
different levels that we have influence
each other is there downward causation
is the notion of causation a useful
notion
between levels in addition to being
inside of levels this stuff is very
relevant to the origin of life why are
there complex systems right life is a
paradigmatic complex system
consciousness and the fact that we have
self-referential understandings of the
world the relationship between quantum
mechanics and classical mechanics and
all these things
almost everything interesting about the
world other than fundamental physics
is part of this big project of
connecting fundamental physics to the
world that we see around us there's a
lot of good low hanging fruit to be
picked in this field thank you very much
thanks for watching
is there are there any questions in the
room or questions
so i was wondering about there was a a
shift from we talked about uh
the
microstate of the universe and then we
talk then about the mentaculous
so we've moved from a microstate to
probabilities which presumably are
dependent on
our uncertainty our measurement
uncertainty
so is that's you know that's the
question of like is that the question of
setting this microscopic
cut off
i guess
it's simply a question of of the real
world of the fact that there is uh
the real world is quantum mechanical so
there's a huge thing working under all
this that i'm not touching on but in
this pretend version of the real world
where things are classical there is a
state of the world a single point in
phase space but we don't know what it is
we have incomplete information about the
world we know where the sun is in the
sky we don't know the location of all of
its atoms okay
so what we do is we invent a probability
distribution for our sakes given the
macroscopic information what is the
probability that we ascribe to all the
microscopic variables we don't know
there are some principal reasons for
inventing some rather than others but if
you were laplace's demon if you knew the
microstate of the world you wouldn't
need to do any of this stuff laplace's
demon doesn't know about entropy or the
arrow of time laplace's demon just knows
the whole world perfectly but we're not
him
so in particular
we have for if we're speaking
probabilistically meaning not being
omniscient
there is some degree of lower entropy
past
and how low that needs to be
depends on our level of not quite
omniscience
it does but happily i know exactly what
you're saying but the dependence is
really really weak
it's pretty clear
the best we can do to describe the early
universe it's a plasma particles with a
certain density with certain
distribution et cetera et cetera et
cetera and given those macroscopic
constraints even if we don't know the
precise density at every point in time
we have a very good understanding of
what the probability of the density is
at different points in space and time
and again within that macroscopic set of
constraints we have a very good notion
of what the micro equilibrium
distribution is so even though in
principle it is dependent on our
observational abilities
if you had a very good computer with
robot eyeballs etc it wouldn't do much
better than we do it's pretty robust
thank you
yes
so if now you take a quantum world you
have the measurement problem and the
projection
postulate
so is it also a way to explain the arrow
of time is it a new way is it related
good so uh i knew this would happen um
it depends on your favorite version of
the foundations of quantum mechanics my
favorite version is the aberdeen or many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics
in which the there is no projection
postulate there is no wave function
collapse there is nothing special called
measurement or observation or anything
like that there is only the evolution of
the wave function as a whole
according to the schrodinger equation
forever and part of that evolution is
branching into different possibilities
so you get a picture that is very very
much like this picture
except it's quantum rather than
classical
and the different parts describe
literally different branches of the wave
function of the universe that become
real in the classical world the
different probabilities like did the
volcano erupt or not one is real and the
others are not anymore in the many
worlds quantum version of it they're all
real with some amplitude but the same
questions arise why was you still need
to uh you still need to have a past
hypothesis that explains why the quantum
wave function of the universe started in
such a very particular place
that's a good question
thanks for the fascinating talk so in
causal inference there's this idea or
principle of independent mechanisms that
postulates that the
the distribution of causes should be
independent in the sense of not sharing
information with the mechanism that
generates the effects from the causes
and
there's some work by dominique yanzing
and colleagues that try to connect this
to the thermodynamic era of time by
postulating that similar independence
should apply to the
initial state and the dynamics of a
system
and
under this you can then show that you
actually have some shared information or
some dependence
between the final state and the reverse
dynamics
which is kind of like break this
asymmetry so i'm wondering if you
if you're familiar with this
work or if not if you have any thoughts
on that and how it maybe connects to
this past hypothesis or the conditioning
on an
independent initial state or maybe
that's related to you know a
low entropy uh
past
i'm not familiar with it at all no um
i'm i'm surprised i'm not because i
certainly have googled those words that
you used but there's probably more than
one piece of work on it um the the
latter couple sentences you said uh
don't sound completely convincing to me
uh maybe i just understand them i know
it was a brief description um i don't
think that the introduction of quantum
mechanics either helps or hurts the
search for an explanation for the low
entropy
initial condition um
there is a you know a whole
uh intellectual project of deriving the
arrow of time without a low entropy
initial condition putting some true time
asymmetry in somewhere maybe because of
quantum mechanics okay i think that's
misguided because number one
there is a low entropy past
and number two once you have a low
entropy past you've explained the arrow
of time
so
doing anything else to explain the arrow
of time i think is not the right thing
to do so
what i would say that whether it's
quantum or classical at heart we have
the same question why did the early
universe have low entropy and that's
fundamentally a cosmology question
without cosmology you can't answer it
there's no principles of simplicity or
symmetry or anything like that it could
have been very high entropy and it just
wasn't and we're not sure why i'm not
sure if that addresses the question
um
so
you showed us this example
where the entropy increases in the
coffee
um but the complexity goes goes up and
then goes uh yeah town
and you were saying oh think about a
jpeg you know how it'd be it'd be easier
to like store this one and this one
harder to store the one in in the middle
but that kind of depends on the basis
that i'm like viewing it in and so if i
have a different basis maybe it's an
unnatural maybe there's a natural basis
for us
and for us
the one in the middle is the most com
complex one so it really depends on your
perspective
and my question is uh
you know
why
why should it not be the case like i'm
i'm wondering
so the the case for entropy here always
going up is has been as you said i've
always seen it going up
but is there a way for me to know that
that's not
based on my viewpoint like is there a
different basis i could have is this
kind of a vague fuzzy kind of question
was there a different basis that i could
have in which
entropy doesn't go up or down or do
weird things it's not a very very fuzzy
question at all it's a very common
question and
i know the answer
sometimes people believe me when i tell
it to them and sometimes they don't so
it's related to the question that was
already asked there is a course graining
that we put on the microstates of the
universe following boltzmann okay and he
says look here's the corresponding
here's a typical path
do a different core screen right imagine
i just take this little tiny ellipse and
i move it down there and i move the
medium-sized ellipse down there then i
could find
that the same trajectory of the universe
is now one in which entropy is
decreasing
all course grainings are created equal
there are right ones and the right ones
are not fixed by arbitrary choices
they're fixed by the laws of physics
when you look you're when you look with
your eyes at the cup of coffee
all that's physics right there's no
version of a detector which would let
you see all the atoms
in that uh
cup of coffee because there's no photons
coming to you from the atoms in the
middle et cetera et cetera right you
have access to certain wavelengths it
gives you certain information that's
what gives us the core screening and uh
you know uh robbie the robot would make
the same course screening as you would
awesome thanks
a whole bunch of questions from zlatan
so i'll have to
just do a couple so uh from tom langauer
is is here an approach to arguments
explaining the past hypothesis or will
we just have to resort to the anthropic
principle oh some of us have theories
to explain the past hypothesis i think
again that's another talk it's not this
talk i think it's probably legitimate
for 98 of science to say the early
universe just had a low entropy and we
conditionalize on that for literally
everything we do but two percent of us
need to be thinking hard about why the
early universe had low entropy without
cheating there's plenty of papers that
have been written on this it's probably
like the biggest
set of
the fraction of papers that are just
fundamentally misguided from the start i
don't know why i'm looking at you i
should look at the camera i guess
um
it the the rules of the game are you
have to explain why the early universe
had low entropy without assuming
anything that by assumption
distinguishes the early universe from
the late universe
so in the picture this is this is
already a very anthropocentric picture
because this is from the early universe
to today but guess what the universe
doesn't end it keeps going right so
we're in the middle of this not at the
end of it but people make arguments like
well the early universe state you need
to start is especially simple in my
model okay or whatever and then it was
hugh price who really the philosopher
who really emphasized why doesn't your
argument apply to the late universe the
late universe is very very different
than the early universe and if you have
some argument for why a certain
condition should be the initial
condition
either
it also applies to the final condition
or you're just smuggling in the
asymmetry so that's the challenge um the
the solution that has been proposed by
uh myself my collaborators is that the
early universe that we call the
beginning is not the beginning it is
just one moment that came from a
pre-existing universe and if you look at
the whole shebang
if you go toward the far far far past
before the big bang the arrow of time is
going the other way
there's a moment of time in the middle
with a minimum entropy not not a minimum
the lowest entropy the universe ever had
but not necessarily low
and it increases in both directions from
that but to make that work physically
cosmologically you really need to wave
your hands pretty fast and i would not
say that we're anywhere close to having
a consensus on what the right theory is
i'll ask one more
there a lot here but so just one more um
from carlos gerardo so if i understand
correctly your explanation of why we
have memories of the past but not the
future
is that macro probability distributions
satisfy the markovian property if we
assume the past hypothesis okay i'm
compute i'm confused about how to go
from the core screening to the markov
property i suspect my confusion comes
from the difference between the two
definitions of entropy you used
i'm sorry
it doesn't that's not why where your uh
confusion comes
from uh
you only need
the the definition i gave for what i
call the macroentropy
is never used as the entropy of anything
by anyone but this talk i was just
trying to make sort of preempt the
possible confusion about the possible
diverging dynamics when you flip coins
or have uh volcanoes explode or whatever
the point is that if all you had was
the
a condition at one time and the laws of
physics all of your extrapolations
statistically about the past and future
had better be equal
in terms of entropy or anything like
that you should have no extra leverage
over the past or the future if all you
have is the dynamics and we do think we
have extra leverage over the past we
have memories and records of it that we
don't have over the future
um
i'm not sure that's answering the
question was that answering the question
[Music]
no
can you just try it one more time just
ask it one more time is it still there
i'll read you the question you don't
ignore it
you explain your explanation of why we
have memories of the past but not the
future is that macro probability
distributions satisfy the markovian
property if we assume the past
hypothesis okay i'm confused about how
to go from the core screening to the
markov property
so okay good yeah um
you need that extra bit of what i call
the local equilibration hypothesis right
so um
yeah so the point is that
um
yeah what what is the point how can i
best say this here would be
the macro distribution through time if i
didn't have the past hypothesis okay
this is some set of random variables
describing the states of different
subsystems the macroscopic subsystems
here's a cup here's a table here's a
volcano or whatever okay that's x1 x2 x3
and at moment two
someone tells me what that distribution
is
um i can use my knowledge of what the
micro variables are not their states but
i know what the total set of micro
variables is i'm assuming
and the local equilibration hypothesis
tells me i know their probability
distribution
right
so
given the macro probability distribution
that's all the knowledge that i have or
need and i can use the laws of physics
to evolve it in both directions either
way
but if i did the entropy of the
individual systems the microscopic
entropy so i have some microscopic
configuration and i calculate the
entropy of the micro variables within
that all the atoms in the cup of coffee
and milk for example
it would go up in both directions and it
would be perfectly markovian in both
directions but that's not the real world
that's not what the world does that
would that would be a world where today
this moment in time was the lowest
entropy moment the universe ever had an
energy would increase in both directions
we need a universe where the entropy was
lower in the past
so we have some extra hypothesis and
it's not that this allows markovian
evolution it's that it doesn't allow it
toward the past
it says that the markovian evolution
only works if you start with the past
hypothesis and work toward the future
if you started at some intermediate time
the evolution to the past is not
markovian because you need to
conditionalize over some future goal
not future but you know what i mean
the the past goal or whatever you want
to call it so it's that extra boundary
condition
that ruins your attempt to reverse the
arrows
i think we are already over time but i
guess we have we will take one more
question maybe
[Music]
please apologize for the question will
be more connected with the assumption of
the two arrows in the big bang than the
causality but i really like it as an
assumption so i'm trying to understand
so you say
one assumption is that in the big bang i
have two splits
two directions of time
and the second one is a universe that we
do not observe at all where at the same
time if we observe it
we would see a universe where
from our perspective we will see
that the effects
cause the causes but for their universe
it is again normal the causes cause the
effects i i would like just one more
comment about that because i found it
really
interesting
so it's not that the big bang is the
moment of lowest entropy is that there
was a moment of lowest entropy so here
is a version of that this picture but
now time is going vertically i'm taking
this from a different talk so here is an
empty universe okay there's nothing
going on there's no matter no galaxies
or whatever so there's no arrow of time
at this moment
except what
the previous
30 slides in this talk talked about is
that there is quantum mechanics and
there is gravity okay so there are
quantum mechanical fluctuations in the
curvature of spacetime itself
and those fluctuations can give birth to
a little baby universe that pinches off
and goes its own way
and that
yeah here's a picture
no one has ever taken a picture of this
this is just a computer simulation but
you know what i mean okay so the point
is that we're we're presuming that even
though there was this universe that was
empty and quiet and we thought it was as
high entropy as it could be so it's just
equilibrium it would stay there forever
in fact there's this very unlikely but
possible quantum fluctuation that gives
birth to a little baby universe and we
have eternity to wait
so in fact even though it's rare it will
happen an infinite number of times
as you go in time away from this moment
and most of these little baby universes
will just collapse in on themselves and
be stillborn but if they have exactly
the right initial conditions they will
puff up and be a universe just like ours
and the process to go from that little
tiny universe to pop up and be just like
ours has a very pronounced arrow of time
until it equilibrates and empties out
which will happen to us about a google
years from now
all of that story can also be told
going toward the past because the
underlying laws of physics don't know
the difference between past and future
and there could even be baby universes
at the same time as this doesn't matter
you can include them if you want the
point is if you wait long enough
all these individual universes will keep
popping into existence more and more of
them and the entropy of the ensemble
increases without bound
so the entropy at any one moment is
finite but there is no upper bound on it
it can always increase and that happens
infinitely far to the future infinitely
far to the past in each one of these
little babies there's a local arrow of
time
from the global point of view that no
observer has
these arrows are pointed in the opposite
direction to these arrows
so it's not that these people would say
effects precede causes they would say we
live in the past
and you say that they would
perfect please thank you very much
[Applause]